what is up everybody it's an iMac here
for anime uproar and today I'm going to
be freaking out over the latest
developments in the attack on Titan
story while attempting to make all my
fangirling sound like a coherent video
I'm not normally the type of person who
loses it over something interesting
happening in a manga chapter but what
just happened an attack on Titan really
changed everything we thought we knew
yet again and this chapter
single-handedly shifted our
understanding of Aaron's entire
character honestly this might be my
favorite
attack on Titan chapter up to this point
so let's talk about everything that
happened right now by the way if you
enjoy the attack on Titan content on
this channel you want to see more please
leave a like to let me know and if you
want me to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell a huge thank you to
all of our anime upper patrons who make
videos like this one possible I'll talk
more about patreon at the end of the
video but now please be warned that this
video will contain manga spoilers we're
gonna be dealing with the latest
developments in the attack on Titan
story so proceed with caution you have
been warned the title of chapter 1 2 1
is memories of the future at least
according to the official translation
that we have and honestly it couldn't
have been a more appropriate title the
chapter begins with Zeke and Aaron still
wandering through grisha's memories
apparently they have been wandering
through his memories for years although
we know that time is out of whack at
this point so it is possible that no
time has actually passed out in the real
world Zeke has finally made his peace
with the fact that Grisha never tried to
brainwash Aaron Grisha was overall a
pretty loving father to his second son
and he allowed Aaron to make his own
decisions in life which is in stark
contrast to how Grisha raised Zeke his
first son it's clear now that Grisha did
learn an important lesson from his first
marriage and he did do his best to make
amends for his past mistakes but after
realizing all of this Zeke has puzzled
Zeke asks Aaron why if Grishin ever
brainwashed him did Aaron still decide
to betray Zeke
why does Aaron keep willingly following
down the same path as his father instead
of using Zeke's plan to finally end
senseless fighting and suffering once
and for all Aaron tell Zeke that the two
of them are different and Aaron has been
the way that he is now ever since he was
born if someone tries to take away
Aaron's freedom he won't hesitate to
take away that person's freedom in turn
Aaron would never accept Marlon
propaganda about how the LD ends are
evil and how the world can only be in
peace if all the LD ends are eliminated
for one thing we know that this
propaganda is completely wrong we know
from our own world the real world that
even without people who can transform
into Titans there is still constant war
and conflict around the globe the fact
that LD ins don't exist in our world
that doesn't stop the people from
pointlessly fighting each other
furthermore Aaron is right to reject the
idea that just because his LD and
ancestors allegedly did something bad in
the distant past he and every other LD
alive today have to suffer the
consequences of their ancestors actions
even though they themselves did nothing
wrong Aaron tells Zeke that he is not
the pathetic little brother that Zeke
wanted him to be and he is not a
convenient brother who can be used by
Zeke Aaron then drops a savage truth
bomb on Zeke because of his traumatic
childhood Zeke has defined himself as a
person through his denial of his
father's wish to restore aldea
even though grisha is dead Zeke is still
obsessed with Grisha and what grishin
did to him and by euthanizing the LDN
Zeke is trying to deny his father's
greatest wish which was to restore aldia
to its former glory to put it simply
instead of saving the LD ends like
Grisha wanted Zeke wants to euthanize
them all
Zeke might claim that he truly believes
that this is the best for everyone but
Aaron implies that Zeke is doing all of
this just to spite his father just to
get back at his father for prioritizing
LD and restoration over his own son it's
not really a moral or philosophical
conviction that is driving Zeke it is
his personal grudge with Grisham Zeke
responds by saying that even if all of
this is true he is grateful to his
father because his father's actions
showed him the truth they showed him
what danger LD opposes to the world and
ironically Grisha will actually save the
world by motivating Zeke to eliminate
the LDN
from this world as Zeke continues to
talk about this Erin isn't interested at
all he is more interested in looking at
grisha's memory of the time when Aaron
first gave his scarf to Mikasa and since
we know how poorly Aaron treated Myka
signed the most recent chapters
something which we can now assume was
just an act to keep Myka sign armed and
safe from Zeke just as Arman predicted
the fact that Aaron is so focused on
this memory with Mikasa and the fact
that his face looks very emotional in
this moment tells me that he still has
strong feelings for her now this channel
is far too sophisticated for shipping I
would never talk about ships on this
channel I am far too much on
intellectual for the nah I'm just
kidding
I totally ship Eren and Mikasa and this
moment gives me hope that it can still
happen red scarf forever boys at this
point Zeke is not amused by how little
attention aaron is paying to him so Zeke
tries to flex on Aaron Zeke reminds
Aaron that he controls the founder and
that he can carry out the euthanasia
plan whenever he wants but because he is
such a nice guy he is not going to just
carry out the plan before he shows Aaron
that he was right about everything all
along only then will he carry out the
plan I mean what could go wrong what
could possibly go wrong with Zeke's
flawless logic let's find out Aaron just
kind of goes with it for now as they
continue their journey through grisha's
memories they see that from a very young
age Aaron wanted to join the survey
Corps and venture outside of the wall he
refused to stay ignorant about the
outside world and a prisoner within the
walls he refused to allow the sacrifices
of everyone who gave their lives to
learn about the outside world be in vain
it is only after seeing Aaron acting
this way that Grisha promises to show
him the basement and what is really
hidden on the inside Grisha probably
decides to do this because he doesn't
want Aaron to spend his life trying to
join the survey corps and venture
outside for nothing Grisha already knows
what the outside world is like and he
already knows that all the Titans are
just LDS were turned into Titans against
their will I think that Grisha was going
to tell Aaron about the basement not
because he wanted to brainwash him or
indoctrinate him but because he wanted
Aaron to know the truth so that he
doesn't die for nothing fighting Titans
were not actually evil and exploring a
world that
already been explored sadly as we all
know Grisham never got the chance to
show the basement to Aaron the memories
then jump to Grisha confronting the
Reese family in the secret complex
beneath the church the same secret
complex that he had discovered years ago
after wall Maria was breached and the
Titans flooded inside the walls Grisha
became desperate for help from the
founding Titan
he tells Freda and the others that he is
an LVN who came from beyond the walls
and he begs Freda and King Carl Fritz
within her to stop the Titans from
attacking the innocent people within the
walls including grisha's family but
Freda simply replies that the audience
cannot escape their sins and the time
has come for all the subjects of Amir to
face judgement the king of the walls
King Carl fritz seems to be speaking
from inside Frieda it's not just Frieda
speaking here Carl Fritz is speaking
through the founding Titan he says that
the Titan power is too much for man to
handle and the tragedy of the type more
is what convinced him of this fact the
King says that someone must keep the
power of the Titans out of the hands of
humans and that is why the founding
Titan power must never fall into the
hands of the weak again because the end
result would be another hell on earth
for that reason King fritz believes that
it is better for all the audience to
just accept their sins and perish rather
than to risk another hellish Titan war
Zeek mentions at this point that he
relates to what Frieda is saying and he
reminds Eren that Grisha is about to go
on and slaughter all of these people
just so he can get what he wants the
founding Titan power Zeek reminds Eren
that he had told him before that it was
this memory the memory of grish are
killing Therese family including the
children that made Eren lose all hope in
Grisha but if you look at Aaron's face
in this moment you will see how he truly
feels Eren is furious when he hears
Frida's logic he is furious at the idea
that king Karl Fritz would so casually
allow all those innocent people to
suffer and without ever knowing why they
are suffering in the first place Grisha
continues to beg and plead with Frieda
he talks about how he has a wife son and
daughter the daughter being the adopted
daughter Mikasa and Grisha talks about
how he lives close to her
the walls were breached but Freda and
King Karl Fritz within her refuses to
budge the king says that the LD ends can
never atone for the human lives that
they took but the one thing that they
can do is prevent the taking of any more
lives beyond the walls and for that
reason as long as the aliens remain
ignorant and accept the world's rage
they are the only ones who will have to
die and no one else Grisha appears
frantic and desperate but Aaron Aaron is
seething Aaron is so angry that both
Zeke and Grisha noticed him at this
point
and Grisha shouldn't even be noticing
him in the first place because these are
just his memories the two of them are in
two completely different times Frieda
says that there is no point in trying to
convince them and even if Grisha tries
to take the founding Titan power from
her he will be unable to use it so it is
pointless Grisha says that he knows that
he can't use the founding Titan power
but he possesses the attack Titan power
which has its own unique ability the
inheritors of the attack Titan have a
tradition of not obeying orders and
resisting the self-righteousness of the
king and that is because the attack
Titan is capable of seeing the memories
of its future inheritors the attack
Titan can see the future through the
future memories of the inheritors that
are yet to come
this definitively confirms that Titans
are able to see the future and in
particular the attack Titans unique
ability is to see the memories of its
future possessors I actually made a
video speculating that this was the case
over two years ago so it is really cool
to have this finally confirmed although
many of us were suspecting that
something like this was the case for a
while now both Zeke and Freda were
clearly unaware of the fact that the
attack time you could see the future
despite having the founding Titan power
Frida was unaware because the vow of
pacifism is keeping her from accessing
the full extent of the founding Titans
power
Grishka prepares to eat the founding
titan and put an end to the royal
bloodline because that is the future
that has already set out for them that
is the future that he presumably already
saw in Aaron's memories but as he
prepares to turn into a Titan Grisha
can't bring himself to do it he says
that he can't bring himself to kill the
innocent Rhys children he is a doctor
his job is to save lives not to take
them Zeke is confused because he knows
that Grisha is supposed to mass
the family and take the founding titan
unless the past had somehow changed but
how is that even possible and that is
when the whole game switches up yet
again and Aaron solidifies his place as
one of the greatest and most intriguing
characters in all of anime and manga in
my opinion even though Grisha seems to
have given up to fight Freeda doesn't
kill him
even as the other members of the Reese
family tell her to kill him so he
doesn't destroy their heaven while these
kids are so naive it's freaking sad
Frieda starts to walk away say what you
will about king fritz but he does take
his valve pacifism seriously we saw it
with fury and Kenny and we see it now
with freidheim Grisha King fritz really
does want to avoid killing whenever
possible although to be fair the secret
police that runs the island on behalf of
the Fritz family is doing a lot of
killing on a daily basis or at least
they were at the beginning of the story
before they were overthrown but this
story is not over yet
Eren the Eren from the future who is
supposed to be just observing these
memories of the past begins speaking to
Grisha
directly he tells Grisha to stand he
reminds Grisha why he came here in the
first place
Eren reminds grish about everything he
had to go through because of the
pacifism of Karl Fritz to death of his
little sister the death of his fellow
restorationist Deena
Ehren Kruger and everyone else who had
to suffer and continues to suffer just
because the royal family refuses to help
its own people
Eren reminds Grisha that he started this
story and he must go through what he
came here to do after being convinced by
Aaron from the future Grisha decides to
go through with his Titan transformation
and he kills Frida takes the founding
Titan power and kills everyone else
except for Rod Reese just as it was
always supposed to happen so it was
Aaron all along Grisha wasn't going to
go through with his plan to steal the
founding Titan and destroyed the Reese
family until future Aaron directly
intervened into the events of the past
and convinced Grisha to do it after the
deed is done
aah crying Grisha asks Aaron is this
what he wanted is he happy now Grisha
clearly didn't want to do what he had
just done but he is convinced that this
was the only way to save el dia
including his family and Aaron was the
one who convinced him that this is the
case he did all of this for Aaron
this wasn't just gracious plan we now
know that it was just as much Aaron's
plan
Zeke looks mortified as Grisha anguishes
on his knees Grisha notices Zeke and
tells him that from here on it won't go
as he wishes it will all be going
Aaron's way and how does Grisham know
this
how does Grisha know what will happen
from now on even though those events
haven't even happened yet in the present
it can only be because gracious saw
Aaron's memories from even further in
the future beyond the point in the story
that we've seen so far
Zeke one of the most intelligent people
in attack on Titan and that's not just
my opinion it's actually according to
his official statistics is absolutely
bewildered by what just happened despite
his grand plan for euthanizing the LD
ends the true mastermind behind the main
events of attack on Titan was not Zeke
it was not Grisha it was not Carl fritz
it was none other than Eren Jaeger
Krisha confirms to Zeke that he has seen
Erin's memories of what will happen next
but he can't believe that it will become
that ghastly this means that we still
have no idea what awaits us in the next
few chapters Aaron has been unleashed
and he isn't taking any prisoners Grisha
embraces Zeke and apologizes to him for
being a terrible father and then he
tells Zeke that he asked to stop Aaron
Grisha keeps implying that Aaron is
about to do something truly insane
something so terrible that even Grisha
who has been to hell and back cannot
comprehend it thanks to this exchange my
curiosity about what is going to happen
next is piqued
what is Aaron about to do is he going to
unleash the rumbling is he going to
level Marlay the entire world I've said
many times in the past that I can't wait
for the next chapter to come out but
that has been taken to a whole new level
after this chapter in particular
suddenly Zeke and Aaron find themselves
outside of gracious memories and back in
the unknown land that is the physical
manifestation of the coordinate Aaron
actually thanks Zeke for bringing him
into grisha's memories because if he
hadn't done that Aaron would never have
been able to do what he just did Aaron
also says that four years ago when he
touched
history us hand he saw memories of
himself in the future within grisha's
memories this means that for four years
aaron has been planning for this moment
guided by a vision of the future that no
one else had access to for at least four
years Aaron has been the mastermind
behind everything that's been happening
and everything that is going to happen
in Zeke's entire plan was nothing but a
red herring the real plan was always
Aaron's plan Zeke says that Grisha told
him to stop Aaron Grisha seemingly
regretted doing with Aaron told him to
do because of how horrible Aaron's plan
ultimately was so in order to stop him
Zeke waste no more time
he tells Amir frits the little girl
inside the unknown land to steal the
ability of all LD ins to reproduce Amir
Fritz hears the command and begins to
move Zeke tells Aaron that there is
nothing that he can do now because he
already commanded him here and she
always does what someone with royal
blood tells her to do Aaron tries to
stop him here but he is still chained up
however at this point Aaron goes berserk
his human face begins to resemble his
attack Titan face and he breaks through
the chains ripping off some of his own
fingers in the process the chapter ends
as Aaron tries to grab Amir and stop her
from carrying out Zeke's euthanasia
command while Zeke insists that trying
to stop her is pointless we have no idea
how Aaron is going to stop him here
Fritz from carrying out Zeke's order but
we know that he must somehow succeed
because Grisha told us that from now on
everything is going to go Erin's way
Zeke will lose on top of being left with
this massive cliffhanger about what's
going to happen next
we are also left with a completely
different opinion of Aaron as a
character Aaron was the one who pushed
Grisha to carry out his plan and steal
the founding Titan killing the Ruiz
family in the process but why did Aaron
do this why would he want the entire
Ruiz family including the children to
die I think the answer is this Aaron
didn't necessarily want the children to
die but as we saw from his face when
Frida was talking Aaron could no longer
stand King Fritz's valve pacifism King
Fritz just stood by and watched as
thousands of his own people were
slaughtered in Marlay and on the island
and he did nothing to protect them
King Fritz took the memories of the
audience on the island so that they
would never even know why they were
suffer
and dying in the first place King Fritz
created one of the most unjust and
unfair kingdoms possible and he did it
all just because he personally felt
guilty about what the LD ins did in the
past about the great titan war from 100
years ago and so on Aaron's entire life
was defined by the suffering of the
aliens on the island at the hands of the
Titans and by extension at the hands of
Marlay his mother was killed right
before his eyes he lost many friends and
comrades he was betrayed and lied to and
he has had enough King fritz might feel
guilty for his own role in the Wars of
the past but this generation of audience
was not responsible for what happened
centuries ago the LD ends of the island
don't even know what actually happened
before the walls were built so they are
in no way complicit with the inn
justices of the past
Aaron was infuriated by the Kings
ideology which called for innocent
aliens of this generation to suffer and
die for the sins of their ancestors
ancestors they didn't even know anything
about Aaron decided that he would do
whatever it takes he would be as
Machiavellian and ruthless as he had to
be for the greater good of this
generation of LD ins if he had to kill a
handful of members of the royal family
people who have been running a
tyrannical police state and controlling
everyone's memories in order to save
tens of thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of Aldean lives then he would
do it what would be the greater crime
sparing the royal family and watching
tens of thousands of other innocent
people die or sacrificing the royal
family for the greater good of every LDN
it's not an easy choice it is not an
ideal choice by any means no one
deserves to die and especially not the
Reese children who in all likelihood
have just been brainwashed and are just
doing what they were told to do but
Aaron made the choice to sacrifice these
people now in order to save the rest of
the people in the island or at least as
many of them as possible
you can definitely understand Aaron's
motivation here even if it's hard to
know whether we ourselves would ever be
capable of making such a difficult
decision and of course we all hope that
we are never put in a situation where we
have to make any decision along these
lines the big question is what happens
now what else does Aaron have planned
and is he about to completely lose it is
he going to level the whole earth with
the rumbling is he going to destroy all
of Marley or is he going to do
something different altogether like
create a 2000 year time loop something
that I talked about in my previous
attack on Titan Theory video about Aaron
and the earth devil I'll link that video
in the description if you want to check
it out whatever happens next this
chapter really changed the game yet
again it confirmed the future memories
theory it showed us that Aaron directly
interfered in the past to make his
father steal the founding Titan power
and it told us that Aaron has access to
even more future memories memories of
events that haven't even happened yet
this means that Aaron has knowledge of
the future that no one else possesses
and he's about to use it to his
advantage in a way that makes even
Grisha shake in fear truly a masterpiece
of a chapter I have nothing else to say
except it was amazing and game-changing
and I am counting the days and hours and
minutes until the next chapter drops
please let me know what you guys thought
of chapter one two one how is your
opinion of Aaron's character changed and
what do you think that Aaron is going to
do next scroll down to the comments and
let me know right now I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more attack on
Titan content on this channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you don't hit the
bell and turn on all notifications you
will definitely miss our future videos
does just how YouTube works feel free to
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest attack
on titan news and updates i want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
upper patrons for supporting our work
and making our videos possible a special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius and on Hell crews on Epic
thank you to all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah al Olin Adam Mary Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Reagan
Harrison and Lord naksan or disciples of
Lord we go himself if you enjoy our
videos and you think they provide value
for you consider
supporting us on patreon link in the
description even a single dollar will
give you access to our exclusive patron
only discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these amazing
people as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]